hello and welcome
to this market entry webinar
a series arranged by design singapore
design singapore council
and this one is about europe
european design market now
host pandemic so welcome and good
afternoon to our friends
in singapore good morning to
our friends in europe good evening
anybody joining from a bit further east
of singapore
australia or new zealand and if you're
joining us from new york
or la and the americas you probably
should be in bed
but thank you very much for learning the
midnight
oil so we're very excited to be here
to discuss this very urgent topic of the
european design market
and where it is now and we are asking
that question
and i am delighted to be joined by a
stella
panel i have with me the design
journalist
rosa bertoli who is the design editor of
wallpaper magazine
and she has really does have her finger
on the pulse across
all areas of design and lifestyle
globally
also delighted to be joined by gabriel
tan of favorable town studio
i'm sure most people are familiar with
gabriel singaporean designer who is
currently
recently moved and living and working in
europe
in porto portugal to be precise
oh and me i'm delighted to be joined by
me i'm tony chambers i'm a creative
director and editor and design
consultant
a graphic designer and typographer by
training
but worked for most of my career in
magazines and publishing
as a junior designer and then art editor
for the sunday times magazine
art director of gq magazine hyundai nest
and then wallpaper magazine for 15 years
first as creator director and then as
editor-in-chief
and a couple of years ago i made the
brave decision to
leap from the comfort zone of publishing
and magazines and it is a very
comfortable zone
to set up my own business tc and friends
which is a design consultancy
and creative agency
and last but not least very happy
to be joined by mabel liu from the
design singapore council
and mabel a little later on will be
telling us more about the very brilliant
business of design program
very importantly we want to hear from
you
so we have a q a session 15 minutes
before the end so 15 minutes
of questions where you tell us what you
want to know
you can ask the panel generally you can
ask individuals you can ask
anything you want about this very
interesting subject there's very urgent
subjects
of the european design market and how
you as a designer can break into that
market
what to do what not to do all questions
are there to be answered by our
panel now i am going to now hand over
stop sharing my screen so you see the
lovely faces more clearly
of rosa and gabriel and i'm going to ask
rosa first and then gabriel
to give a brief biography and
introduction to them i'm sure most of
you are
familiar with their work but i think it
would be
nice to hear from them their background
their journey
in design so first over to you rosa tell
us about rosa bertley
thank you hello everyone as always it's
a bit strange to talk to a screen but um
i know you're all there so welcome my
name is rosa bertili
and and as tony said i've been the
design editor of wallpaper magazine
since 2014. i have lived in london for
15 years now but i am originally from
italy
and my hometown is near udine in the
heart of the furniture district um in
the northeast
and companies like morozo
[Music]
just to name a few which i'm sure you
all know um they've been literally at my
doorstep
growing up so living there has always
made it obvious to me how important
design and furniture are as
industries and in society
at wallpaper i oversee um
both digital and print content as well
as some special design-led
initiatives and some of which actually
led me to work with
several designers from singapore in the
past
few years for my work i
regularly speak with designers and
companies from all over the world
and it's been particularly interesting
in the past year
to stay in touch because everyone really
wanted to stay in touch and talk
about what was going on so despite
having missed the global design calendar
as i'm sure everyone
has felt i feel like i've been speaking
to brands and creatives more and more
people wanted to talk about product and
design but also
how their companies were doing um um
and i'm in the fortunate position to be
happy to be able to have these
conversations
um regularly but even more so this year
so i hope to bring
some of that insight into that session
today
um i've also co-authored a book about
london architecture with design
journalist sujata berman
which came out a couple of years ago and
if you're ever in town when travel is
allowed again
um i recommend it actually as a quite a
fun guide to explore the city
by foot um i also work um
as a consultant writer and on different
communication
strategies with different brands um many
of them
are italian and it's a pleasure to be
here with tony gabriel and mabel
today i hope you enjoy the webinar and
thank you for having me
thank you rosa can i just ask one
question there um
which is this question rosa and i worked
together for many years
um and actually isn't the question i
ever asked you and it just occurred to
me
your birthplace so growing up in this
area that's anybody who knows the
italian
design and furniture business know that
this is
the hearts and that's the center of the
manufacturing when you were young
were you aware of that was design
furniture
and um that it was it something you were
conscious of
um obviously you are now but was it
something as a
growing up you knew this is an important
zone
for design and furniture i think you
were aware of it in the sense that
say you'd be driving around with your
parents and you'd see a big factory
or you know a big hq with the word
moroso and it always looked really
striking
and um so you you knew that these
entities existed and
you heard about them maybe more that if
you had grown up probably in an area
where
um there were in these big furniture
factories and you know you knew of
friends whose parents worked there so it
was it was a natural part of society so
not
uh not furniture or design as a thing
but as just a part of everyday life and
i think
um you know after a while you notice the
ads in the papers
from all these companies and you start
to figure out that this is all the
system and then obviously
um when i arrived at wallpaper i did a
without the expectation of becoming a
design journalist at the beginning
but then all these names kept popping up
and i thought oh i know i know these
people i know these companies
um you know i grew up with these names
and you start putting all the pieces
together and
realize what the design world really is
and then you go on and on and you
realize how
how big it is and how much it uh it
stretches out and i think
when when you see these names you don't
realize that people
know them all over the world you know um
i come from from a very small town and
not many people
know about it but in the design world
they instantly know
where udine is because of all these
companies so
um i guess i have put the pieces
together growing up
and and then arriving at wallpaper but
i've realized i had this understanding
um of furniture design as a as a
business system as well
so it's destiny in a sense you ended up
in the caribbean you did that's
fantastic
well thank you rosa now i'd like to ask
gabriel
your background your biography
we'll be talking in more detail later
about your work
but how did gabriel tan
start his career from an early age and
how did he end up where he is now
thanks tony yeah i'm hi i'm everyone i'm
gabriel tan
um i have my own studio called gerotown
studios since
2016. my career started in 20
i would say 2005 when i was in the third
year of university i
um i participated in a few design
competitions
and was lucky to be able to travel to
tokyo design week stockholm future
design days milan design week
before i graduated because of these
competitions
um and that really opened my world to
uh opened my eye to the world of design
eventually after i graduated i i set up
a studio with
three other designers one was my
classmate wendy
and two other designers from argentina
um that were based in barcelona at the
times and and we
we called our company out of stock
design because we four of us met in
stockholm
so it's a bit of a tongue-in-cheek
wordplay what was it called out of
out of stock design just so excellent
yeah
and we exhibited um yeah for like
uh four years consecutively at the milan
design week three years at saturday day
and one year in in totona
and before we actually only in our last
year
i think in a fourth year that we we met
some companies like in a jose
plus station and finally got some
um traction to to start our our business
so it wasn't it wasn't a straightforward
journey uh because it took a few years
before our work
got into production and eventually we
started designing for more companies
both
in singapore and in europe and in 2016 i
made a decision to
to start my own studio
working primarily with
manufacturers in in japan europe
and and the u.s and also doing some
interior design
through another company called studio
antimatter
that that i started as well in 2019 i
decided to
to create my own accessories brand
called origin
based in portugal and
after i that was when i
eventually made a decision to to move to
porto uh
which happened last year
and was the move to portugal this the
inspiration was literally because you
started
this over this other project or was it a
love of the place
was it a personal or a professional
decision or a
or a conflation of the two
yeah i was since the beginning of my
career i
wanted to have some
experience living and working in europe
because i
was mainly or i saw myself working
more with european brands and i felt
that
the handicap that i had was often
yeah the face-to-face element where i
could only travel to europe
maximum four times a year and also
there were times when i when i came to
europe for meetings and meetings were
canceled at the last moment and then you
kind of feel a little bit silly
uh at the airport when somebody tells
you that oh so and so can't make it
tomorrow and then you're like okay but i
flew like 16 hours
so i felt that it was it was a necessary
step
uh right from the since years ago but
um i think that big push was yeah when i
when i wanted to to start my own brand
and after i started
in portugal uh i realized that it was
not really
possible to manage a company from
from singapore not for the long term at
least
not when you had the ambitions that you
clearly have and i think that's
something that's so
significant about you gabriel and we'll
elaborate on this later
in terms of you are clearly a very
talented designer from a creative
perspective
but i think you have a real
entrepreneurial spirit and you're
adventurous and brave and i think that's
something to
we'll keep in mind when we talk later
about your specific work
and the fact that you are now a
singaporean designer
um working in europe working from europe
but that's thank you for that background
gabriel all good stuff that we will
touch on a bit later
i'm going to share a screen again now as
we go into the next section of our
webinar
[Music]
and this is really the
crux of what we've done in the last
month or so primarily rosa
rosa and myself and gabriel's helped a
little bit too there's a reminder here
again the questions do get your
questions in into the q
a box we really want to hear what you
want to know
but um for the last few weeks month
we have been reaching out to the leading
design brands
um from italy france germany switzerland
the uk
and denmark to get their views on
how things have been and how they feel
they will be very importantly
after this really rather traumatic and
extraordinary year we've had and
the good news is that the news is
positive
we've um the feedback we've had
has been really very positive for the
design
industry generally i think that bottom
line is
the world has never needed design
and good design more than it does now
and never needed good designers more
than ever because designers as we know
solve
problems and we have a lot of problems
um so yeah we as an industry we are
needed
more than ever so thank you to all these
great brands that we reached out to
across these countries
denmark france germany switzerland italy
and the uk we got
great feedback from the top people
these top brands from ceos chief
marketing officers
design and research people and a quick
take
away quick sort of headline some
headline figures before
i ask rosa to give to elaborate more on
um some more of the details and a more
informal
take on those conversations but 90 of
the brands that we spoke to
and the people that we spoke to said
that despite this initial dip
obviously at the beginning of the
pandemic but sales figures were
actually stable or up at the beginning
of 2021 which is extraordinary
very important one this 85 said that the
digital tools initiatives that they had
implemented
this past year will definitely be a key
part
of their strategy moving forward not
unsurprisingly 90 possibly more
said that sustainability is key a key
aspect of the future of design and
furniture manufacturing
so say that is more evident now than
ever
and 25 percent mentioned
from their own volition this wasn't a
question we asked them directly
but said that there'll probably be more
local showrooms globally
so interactions and showrooms
across the globe this is an important
asset for their company
to face this post-pandemic era
so that's good news as well for
designers in singapore
that you might be seeing more activation
happening from these brands
a few a few more key headline
statements which i'll whiz through here
we don't have time to dwell on them
but you will be getting you will be able
to access a recording of this so you can
dwell on these
facts and figures and quotes more but
being
14 up growth in asia pacific and
actually they'll be launching
more collections throughout the year
rather than focusing on
one or two so it's been great
information here from the brand director
of moroso that collaboration between
brands
and companies could be far more
important now and it's a turning point
minotti and quite a number of the other
big italian brands
analyze that how important now the home
is and that is actually it's the center
of our lives
and that has been a great asset and an
improvement in their business
more people focus on the home similarly
from casino ceo luka fuso
home is so important and definitely
they're introducing new designers
in 2021 and going forward so
positive words there similarly from
frau importance in the world of the home
has actually been this has been an asset
and design furniture design lifestyle
this is something that
far from being damaged by this pandemic
this is one of the
silver linings which means we are more
focused on the home
positive for cartel one of the brands
that really did highlight sustainability
as being one of the most important
things
flex form again positive
they launched all the products and
collections they had planned
and importantly that video and digital
solutions
really aided them um it's so
positive in terms of the things they
fast-tracked and it was a
really this digital communication which
rosa will will verify when she talks in
a moment that
italy was possibly quite a bit behind in
digital technology and communication but
they've really fast-tracked
um the development there lovely quote
here from
karola um from the ceo of living davani
um again emphasizing that it's such an
integral part of our life
furniture interiors but she has advice
to emerging designers
you must learn from rejection rejection
is not necessarily negative
don't give up rejection is a starting
point to reflect and improve
be humble and curious
um in scandinavia in denmark uh
great brand gooby and let's see how
klaus wonderful guy he gives a great
tip here for emerging designers that
concepts or strong concepts
are so important and not just in
prototype you have to really analyze
that this will be a product that will
work
and be appropriate for that brand and
work as a whole
collection is to demonstrate design
ingenuity and craftsmanship
and the context of the piece once all
these things are in place
the other important thing is that they
need to feel that a relationship
with that designer is possible a
long-term relationship but there is
mutual respect
gabriel is going to go into more detail
in that later
usn the great swiss company
their prediction his prediction the ceo
for 2021 is that sustainable
design is not sufficient that's a given
circularity the secular economy
psychology is a must
and good is simply not good enough i
think that's a fantastic quote
fantastic mantra we really now have to
raise the bar
and i think all these great companies
and great designers that we are talking
to today
you've got to be the best you can
possibly be
the german companies front book again
great advice
to designers
hoping to break into this european
market and work with these companies you
know they receive hundreds of proposals
they always look at them
but please please please really target
your proposal
and your your your work and your what
you what you want to do to that company
understand that company do your research
to your
real background nothing worse than just
sending your entire portfolio
with a standard email dslr or madam of
course you would never do that but it's
i think it's wise advice and he's
he's saying that i really understand the
brand um
nice comment from the ceo of classicon a
german company that you know and there
she's wishing and hoping for face to
face again
they've all said that the digital um
encounters and and zoom
has been a great assistance but there's
nothing like the real thing they really
want to meet people
and that's how great things happen into
the uk
wonderful brand benchmark and john
sidcliffe the co-founder
a focus on health and well-being and
good product good materials are
healthy and make one feel better
good design is good for your well-being
and a good tip for designers and
emerging designers particularly
understand how things are made and he
gives a good anecdote
when thomas heatherwick great architect
and susana was young
he spent time at their workshops and
really learned how
materials work and how you put things
together and just to close
at home here in london ben evans who
runs the director and co-founder of the
london design festival it's a very
positive message here
is that london is really reconnecting
now they actually had the london design
biennial at somerset house in june so
just around the corner and they're
confident
that is going to happen both physically
and virtually but very very confident
absolutely by
the autumn september the london design
festival will be
all singing and dancing and of course we
are in a fortune position the vaccine
rollout has been extraordinary in the uk
but i think hopefully this is september
this late summer and september is gonna
be we're gonna be back
um so rosa thank you again rosa did most
of the legwork on this
um with with myself and got this
connection but
i'm just going to stop sharing now and
get rosie to just elaborate a bit more
on some of these facts and figures but
from a personal perspective again you
having your finger on the pulse
coming from that design area it means so
much to you from a personal level
also a professional level gives a few
more headline quotes and again
this very positive vibe we're getting
from these great brands
yeah so i think um you know this is this
is a great time to be a designer
um and if you look back historically any
time of crisis has been followed by a
time of reconstruction
and the pandemic has definitely
highlighted design flaws
in the way both of our society and
everyday lives are designed
and these need to be addressed sooner
rather than later so we need
good creative thinkers and for all that
and as tony mentioned as all the people
we spoke to mentioned design is very
much in demand
having spent so much time at home has
made us reconsider
furniture but also objects and habits
and so things that are maybe less
tangible but have design
and at their heart and and this plays a
huge role
in in this context and for a while i
thought maybe it was a cliche to think
that
you know a series of lockdowns would
result in stronger demand for domestic
design but
as you saw um from a previous slide 90
of the companies
we spoke to said that they saw a growth
or a stable financial situation after
quite a short period of negative results
so it is
definitely not a cliche it's true and
the numbers prove that
and so whether this initial enthusiasm
for the home
will last um it matters less i think
what is important is that the current
generation realizes that
um there are things about the domestic
environment we didn't think about before
and again this is all about design
and we need new systems um objects that
can perform different functions
um and and ways to live the home that
um are different from before so anything
that is
you know multifunctional built to last
um
will definitely um be more successful
um we also need to have designs that can
anticipate our needs help us face times
of crisis
and actually a personal example every
year
wallpaper gathers a jury and to vote on
what are our
best designs of the year and what won
this year um
from the domestic design and life
enhancer categories were a collection of
antibacterial tiles
by italian company marathi and a hand
washing station made in
nigeria by nifemi marcus bello a local
designer
and these are products that are very
specific to the specific historical
moment
but they should always be part of our
lives we should always be thinking like
this so i think we need to put some of
these systems into place
and from the 20 conversations that we've
had
um with tony and with different
companies from all over europe
they um these are the important things
um that we that we found came out of
this conversation
um and this can be translated into
practical advice for anyone wanting to
get into the european design market at
this time as i mentioned before
most companies mentioned a design that
is flexible
multi-functional able to adapt to
contemporary lifestyles
and the companies that already had this
kind of design into place
see their products and go much further
um
quality of design and manufacturing and
so a very thoughtful
considerate design pays off and again
companies that
actually all the companies we spoke to
had absolutely fantastic
quality and they all
saw that go very far um as we said
before the pandemic has accelerated the
technological and digital renaissance
also in brands that were
always based on a more traditional
communication model
and so the ability to communicate
effectively
and use digital tools and implement
digital strategies and operate in a
both um real life but also virtual and
digital world is increasing increasingly
important so any designer wanting to
get into design market need to have this
um absolutely spot on and be able to
implement this communication and as we
said
sustainability um is not enough we need
to think about the next
the next step for that so um anyone
who wants to design today needs to be
very well versed in sustainability
materials innovation and and then
another thing
which we thought was very interesting
was the brands that said that they
already had a system in place in a
specific territory
were able to um operate in that
territory where elsewhere for example
things were locked down
so having a good sales network showroom
partnership with local stores and i
think
um for a designer already in that
territory they can be an asset to a
brand to help them
um work there better and maybe gabriel
could tell us a bit about um this level
yeah that's a really interesting point
rosa said you took because it's um
something that gabriel switches on in a
moment but thank you so much that's
brilliant
insight and again um all the great
feedback we've had
from from these brands and that the top
people these bands are ceos
um designers and marketing
executives um we can make that available
to everybody
um a more um thorough
piece of information on that but i'm
going to share screen again
because we're now going to join gabriel
and his presentation
gabriel are you with us yes
thanks tony pleasure so this is the view
from gabriel gabriel town who gave us an
introduction his biography before
but we have a wonderful presentation
here from gabriel which is going to talk
us
through which talks about the business
culture primarily at the beginning
his journey some of his work we have a
selection of his work which i think is
just wonderful pieces of design and
and great to see a contemporary designer
from singapore so successfully operating
globally um and also some tips and
advice
and something so so gabriel here you are
working in your studio in singapore
and i think the picture on the right is
in japan i believe
i'm one of your brands but but talk us
through this and and what you
your sense of you as a designer
contemporary designer operating now
what the business culture is and how
one does break into the european market
yeah thanks tony i i wanted to share
some thoughts regarding
my my experience working with different
companies
especially in europe that um the
i think the focus is really about
building long-term relationships and
not so much about the individual design
um because
i think when when companies are trying
to decide which designers to work with
it's not so much about whether that
that design you present on the table is
is great or not but it's whether they
see
uh if they can collaborate with with
someone over
a longer period of time especially now
with the pandemic i think
more companies are seeing uh are wanting
to
uh kind of clean up their collections or
trying to clean up
their way of working or collaboration
such that
to work with a trusted pool of a smaller
group of people
but to go deeper in in their
relationships with them
so it's definitely not not as
easy as what i thought it was when i
when i first started when
you're presenting prototypes at the fair
and you're thinking that okay like you
know
i have if i created a good ideas um
people would want to
to produce them or to collaborate with
me but it's
then you realize that you you have to
show
your products for a period of time and
meet someone every year
over three to five years before
people gain any form of respect or or
trust uh in
you as a designer do you think trust is
important
it's more about sorry
i trust that you will stay in the
business yeah
because many designers uh they show
their prototypes or or they exhibit but
then they do not have the stamina
to last uh more than a couple of years
and in the end
they may switch industries or they they
get a
corporate design job somewhere designing
electronics for example
um so i think to be a furniture
designers requires that persistence and
like what um corolla of uh
living divani said you need to be able
to take rejection on the chin
and to um to continue pushing on
i remember last year at imam cologne
when i when i flew 16 hours for two
meetings
i had my bag stolen at the first meeting
right under the table when i was
presenting my work
and in the second meeting the
the person that i was supposed to meet
uh basically could not meet me because
uh
he had a last minute appointment so you
know uh
at that point i felt like yeah you
sometimes you do question yourself you
know why why do you fly 16 hours for two
meetings
just to lose your passport and money and
then
they miss the second meeting due to
circumstances that you can't control
i think it can only get better exactly
i think that's really yeah persistence
rather than shots and pictures is
important let's look at some of your
beautiful work
which has come out of this philosophy of
um
of this tenacity this natural tenacity
you have combined with
creative flair so tell us about this
uh yeah i mean the stove chair was
actually one of the first designs
that um
that got into production after i started
my own studio
and it was with a brand blast station
which i knew from from my days uh
with other song design so blast station
is an interesting company from sweden um
and i think we first met in 2009
and uh out of without a stock it took us
like five years
to rebuild a friendship with them to
finally get a piece in production with
them that they liked so in 2014 i think
we launched
a lounge chair for them and after i
started my studio in 2016 i
presented this idea to to the owner of
blastation johan and he
he liked it and he decided to put it
into production but
it was a relationship that started here
for for more than seven years already
so we already had a friendship a
previous collaboration
and the idea of this chair was to have a
chair that was
very small like i was thinking what
could possibly be the smallest
chair imaginable that would still be
comfortable
and one that was small enough and
lightened not to be hung on the wall
like how the shakers used to do in the
past
these gorgeous houses yeah the air vases
are for menu which which was a brand
that
i always wanted to collaborate with
since many years
and actually had dialogue with them many
times
but nothing really happened for for a
couple of years
and eventually they they sent me a brief
for
for designing a sculptural glass vase
um that they wanted
to yeah so it was more in response to a
specific brief
and and and they liked it but it was
also a result of a dialogue over
at least three years here
and the idea is is to to have a material
quality to to glass face of course um
there are glasses of material that that
is quite new to to me as
a designer working in singapore because
we do not have glass blowing industries
but having uh visited glass factories in
germany and
in portugal i had to learn to understand
the material before
being able to design anything that was
to be feasibly produced here it was
great and these beautiful
amarim cork panels yeah um
this was originally so i i met amari
one of the largest producers in the
world uh during a vacation
to portugal in 20 i think it was 2014
where one of my clients actually
recommended i visited a visited them
because i was asking about the cog
industries in portugal
so i visited some fascinating production
facilities
um and i kept in touch with with my
contact at amarillo when i was working
on the interior project in singapore
a dual residence show flat i asked them
if they were
if they could do some bespoke panel that
i i designed
so i designed these panels the quality
was was pretty small but they agreed to
do it
um in in the view of possibly
commercializing these designs uh
in the near future so
and eventually um
the brand called abstractor from sweden
which which i was
in touch with through another designer
saw these panels and and liked the the
concept of using
cork as an acoustic panel and they asked
if i could
if i could design another shape they
didn't really like the previous shape
but they like the idea of of using
corkus
as a acoustic panel because they were
mainly using a
kind of uh felt ped felt as as
the main panel materials and then i
connected the two companies so that they
could um
collaborate because uh most of the co
production globally is in portugal
anyway so um
i arranged for a factory visit for for
the ceo of abstractor and
and we visited the factories together
and then we
eventually we developed this design
between amorim myself and
abstractor yeah wonderful so very rich
and uh a deep relationship you've built
there with
with the brand that's been very fruitful
which is
lovely to see conrad shop again
and the conrad shop um was actually
introduced to me by one of my production
partners in
singapore malaysia and they
they were also one of my first clients
after i started my studio in 2016
and we have designed many products for
them
um and uh it was
it was a very good collaboration because
i have a really good relationship with
them and i could show them designs
anytime
even just over text message we we have a
mutual trust because we have done many
many products together
um and yeah this is a collection of uh
case goods um that if i'm not wrong this
is doing very well
at the current shop right now and also a
stool and bench collection that
was one of my early designs back in 2016
that that they also put into production
so this is an example of having a client
that you can
um that you feel close to that you are
not afraid to share even
sketch ideas that you you could you know
that
they will always be receptive
to to new ideas and um
and there is a mutual trust between us
um and that is what i i hope to to build
with with each and every one of my
clients to work with a
not to work with like a huge amount of
companies but
to have deeper relationships with a few
sure ah now tell us about origin this is
the
um the origin of your move to portugal i
suppose
um as well as it being a brand that
you've
started and developed but with a great
great story behind it
yeah origin is a is a result of
different observations over the years i
mean i i've observed that many brands
are producing
um products in one country and branding
it with the culture of another
and i i felt
i mean i i kind of have mixed feelings
about that as as a designer because i'm
also partly contributing to that i
designed for for brands
and we understand that yeah i mean in
the end design is
is a business and it's not possible to
uh
if you if you are brand from denmark or
germany for example it's not often
possible to produce everything there
due to the high production cost so it's
it's obvious that uh you you need to
look for
if you want to sell your products at an
affordable price to consumers you need
to produce in
in regions where they are more
industrialized production or handcrafts
for for a more affordable price so i i
discovered that portugal was was a place
where many brands were actually
producing
in europe and
then i saw that there wasn't actually
brands in portugal
or not so many brands in portugal that
were really promoting
uh lo that their their locally made
products all the
all the portuguese designers which which
i found were very talented
so i started first by by collaborating
myself with with one of the craftsmen
uh to do these faces in in baroprato
which was which i discovered was a
virtual tradition that was vanishing in
portugal
it's a kind of black terracotta uh clay
that is fired
under the ground in the pit uh where
where you bury the pieces with soil and
because the soil kind of
[Music]
takes away by burying them it
it takes away all the oxygen and that's
why the pieces are turned black
creates like a natural high pressure
cooker
by by having the soil burying all these
pieces and then you basically fire them
with
with firewood uh by digging a kind of a
drain or a garlic to feed the firewood
into this
underground pit it's super labor
intensive process
that's why not many people want to do it
and it was fascinating to me yeah
and then i brought in other designers to
to collaborate with them both portuguese
as
well as international uh there was one
one year where i organized a kind of
workshop after the milan fair
where i asked people who are interested
and
designers i like to to fly into porto
and i and i rented a
house for them to stay in and then we
went in like four different cars
in a large entourage to visit all these
craftsmen or
16 designers um and
and then those who um
eventually had ideas uh we we developed
products together like these the bowls
by canadian designer zoe
where she designed these bowls made of
three different types of portuguese
marble
that are glued together and then after
that machine
and uh yeah i mean for me origin is
about building a community
between the portuguese craftsman
and the international design community
and it's not so much about myself i only
designed one
one product arranged for for for my own
brand um
and the rest were collaborating with
both portuguese and international
designers
um and discovering the reception being
sorry to introduce
reception from the portuguese crafts
people i presume it's been a
positive thing they're being employed
maybe getting their their skills tested
by
different contemporary designers is it's
i presume it's a
beneficial reciprocal beneficial yes i
mean
i i had this conversation with with joao
who who made my
my chart vases uh recently when i was
there to document
uh his his firing
of the ceramics with with ines uh our
film and and videographer um and he
he spoke in portuguese to me uh ines
translated
and basically he was saying that
he's super happy to have his pieces you
know being sold at
in the us through design within reach or
to being sold at different countries
around the world
um they're being sold in tokyo in oslo
in stockholm and he said that he as a
craftsman that is
he said he would never be able to reach
an international audience
without this collaboration um and he's
also happy that i gave him credit you
know that he's not an invisible
craftsman
just making my my things yeah
and yeah and and he he expressed
how happy he was about this
collaboration and he said that
there were people in in his town of
barcelos that even came up to him and
asked
are you the guy who who does uh work for
for origin
you know even very local um encounters
and he said that it seems that people
are noticing your brand and he said
he's happy for that yeah you've turned
him into a designed superstar
i find it very interesting that you
mentioned the name of all the craftsmen
um who made the pieces i don't see that
very often and i think
it just brings a a much much deeper
dimension to
to the collection and like true
collaboration with the artisans so i
think that's
definitely a very positive credit where
it's due
which often yeah exactly i find that
closing thoughts because you put
together some nice
thoughts here about yeah from your
perspective of course this is an
individual's perspective but a very
good perspective from the great work
you've done on the
ambition and and uh a very proactive
way of operating as a designer
entrepreneur but talk us just through
these briefly before we move on because
i think there's some great
things there about the long-term
personal business developments you've
said that
trust investment you say is so necessary
and perseverance
yeah i think that um in order to
to make it or or just to make a living
out of this as as a furniture designer
uh is
a lot about the long-term
investment in your own personal growth
in my own personal growth at least for
what i and also looking at it
as a long-term project rather than
something that yields immediate results
and because you are making trips
to visit people without any promise of
immediate projects
and and you know that yeah maybe
it's not something that you you you put
x amount of dollars in
and you will get x amount of dollars out
it
involves a lot of different things also
a bit of fortune i mean a bit of luck a
bit of
personal chemistry with with people that
you meet
whether there is chemistry or not and
also you need perseverance but also you
need to be calm
because things don't progress the same
speed as they do in
in singapore or asia
and you need to work at the pace of of
the brands or
of the people you want to work with and
then i realized after after starting
origin as well i mean i have designers
chasing me constantly asking
when is the you know how is it going
with the designs that they sent to me
that that i liked and and you know how
our prototypes going but sometimes yeah
if you when you're managing a brand you
have to deal with
so many things as well as a pandemic
yeah that is slowing production down and
it's not possible to
uh to develop as new products as fast as
we
want to um so it's a balance between
common perseverance i think and also um
giving a chance to younger companies i
know yeah i like this some designers
have maybe
not want to work with brands yes
that's a really good point sorry i think
i think that's a great point to close on
um but yeah look for the next generation
of brand builder relationship because as
you say it's all about trust
it's about understanding a brand and the
longer you work with them
the more that will that trust will
develop and yeah
stay calm and carry on as we say but um
thank you gabriel that's absolutely
wonderful insight from
a designer and an entrepreneur i'm now
going to hand over to
mabel um mabel liu from design singapore
council and she's going to share some
key information
on the very brilliant business of design
program and also she'll introduce our q
a session still getting
some great questions in send any more
don't be shy get them in there we want
to hear from you
but i will hand over now
to mabel okay thanks
thanks tony um thanks tony uh and rosa
and gabriel for
you know your generous insights and your
sharing just now so um as tony has
mentioned i'd like to take this chance
to
share more about the business of design
program and for those of you who have
joined us for the earlier webinars
please bear with me for the next few
minutes while i share a bit about
the program so the business of design
program aims to grow the export value of
singapore designs through building mind
share
in both business to business and
business to consumer markets around the
world
this two year long program will address
targeted aspects of developing the
capabilities of participating design
firms
this includes mentorship access to
networks and brand storytelling
to increase their competitiveness and
demand on the global stage
the second round of the body program
aims to generate new business
opportunities for up to eight
established singapore design studios and
brands
who have the potential to
internationalize in markets such as
europe and asia including japan and
southeast asia
to grow businesses and propel them
globally the program encompasses three
key phases
for the first phase dsg will appoint a
panel of in-market consultants
like tony to guide design studios and
brands in their pitch to secure overseas
business opportunities
the consultants will also connect them
to relevant business circles
while providing mentorship for
follow-through these business circles or
leads include property owners and
specifiers for those who are seeking
commercial contract projects
brands and manufacturers for those who
are seeking consultancy projects
and global or regional retailers and
distributors for those who are seeking
buyers
these consultants will be selected based
on their networks and influence and are
expected to have convertible business
leads in their markets
the second phase of the program
comprises participants potentially being
provided funding to engage a brand
strategy agency
this will help to enforce quality
perception in their brand
and facilitate stronger recall dsg will
also organize a series of media training
sessions
for participating design firms and the
support for this second phase will be
provided on a co-funding basis
lastly the program will culminate in a
themed collective showcase and an
established international showcase
platform in 2022
working with in-market consultants this
approach will raise international
standing of singapore
design and interest buyers from target
markets in asia and europe
and to support interested design firms
that are keen to internationalize
in understanding the commitment required
in entering new markets
dsg has co-organized a series of market
entry webinars including today's session
in addition to the body program so these
webinars are also part of an ongoing
effort to provide resources that support
singapore design community
so the open call for beauty participants
is currently open
and it will close on 22nd april so i'll
just quickly run through
the eligibility and selection criteria
for the program so in terms of the
eligibility criteria the applicant must
be a singapore registered design firm
from any of the following fields
furniture and lifestyle product design
studios
multi-disciplinary design studios that
cover furniture and livestock product
design as a part of their offering
design driven and offer lifestyle
product brands that work with singapore
designers to launch
product lines the lead applicant must
also be a single citizen or a permanent
resident
so in terms of the selection criteria
the bod program prioritise
prioritizes established design studios
and brands to fulfill the following
criteria
having a compelling and differentiated
brand philosophy
and aspiring towards good design which
impacts positively on the environment
culture society or the economy having
strong business fundamentals and being
able to readily scale up to meet
international demand
so to do so the participant must for
example operate with a sound business
model
and have sufficient resources or be
prepared to scale to meet
through a network of production partners
lastly having a good understanding of
the commitment required in entering a
new market
so we really strongly encourage
interested applicants to
attend the market entry webinars that
they're keen to expand into
so i hope this sharing provides an idea
of what the business of design program
is about
so um if you'd like to find out more
information about the program you know
please scan the qr code that's currently
on the screen
um before we you know pass you uh before
we start the q a session you know please
scan the qr code um yeah and i think
we can start the q a session now maybe
to kick things off
um gabriel would you like to share a
little bit about your
experience in being part of the body
program you know in the first edition
um yeah sure um i think the the body
program helped me to grow a lot
personally as as well as
talking about the the amount of meat
things that i had in the past
a year or 18 months which
with companies that i was not able to
reach before
and of there was obviously a certain
sense of nervousness when you walk into
some of these
heritage brands companies and visiting
their factories
but after doing it a few times um
you realize that yeah it's not such a
big of a deal
as much as you make it out to be in your
mind
because yeah i think it's it's
all about getting used to it and
presenting your work and and
after a while you don't feel like a fish
out of water anymore
and i mean i think the the tangible
results would only come in in a couple
of years
is if there will be some collaborations
happening i
i believe that there will be but it
requires patience and also the pandemic
obviously didn't
really put things in check a little bit
but
i am confident that this yeah this
program will will yield results but
probably in two or three years time
and yeah thanks for sharing about that
and i think
one question that did come to mind you
know when you were sharing about your
experience of moving to portugal was
that
i mean is that something you would also
advise other singaporean designers to
to take on or is it um enough
for them to travel you know when board
is open again
to travel regularly to meet potential
clients in europe
i think it's a very personal and
business
specific decision um because
of course um there needs to be a system
to to work uh for me i still have my my
singapore studio
running um and while i tried to grow
a second studio over here and it's not
so easy for for myself or for
anyone to just up and move
but i think it's more about
how each person's own business function
if they need if the singapore side of
business
requires uh the business owner to be
there
for regular face time then maybe it's
better to to travel to europe and
commute for meetings
but if yeah in my case i was able to
set up my studio in a way that i was
my presence my physical presence was not
really required
absolutely required in singapore and as
long as i
if i frequently return to singapore for
for key meetings or milestones that will
be
that will work fine for my office here
thank you
we also did have some questions that
came in earlier before the webinar
so uh maybe tony you could uh or rosa
you could answer this one
um which is to what level do potential
customers
typically like to see concepts so um in
terms of sketches prototypes basic
renders
photorealistic renders with supporting
environments um do you have a sense of
this
by customer clients i presume customer
clients
i think it's probably something for
gabriel as well because he has more
first-hand
experience in presenting but the sense i
get in rosie i think he'll
back us up here i think these clients
these
uh brands you know they're all
business people but they're from
creative
routes they are creative people and i
think sketches ideas
the you know the the more
curious and strange the better i think i
think
people like to see new ideas more so now
than ever
they don't want predictability so i
think if you're presenting
things that show how this works how the
brain works and how that
created that strange creative um parts
of the brain that human beings have if
you're
expressing that i think it can only be a
positive thing
um and i think we that's right isn't it
rosie we got that kind of feedback
they're looking for passion they're
looking for a point of difference and i
think
more than ever now not only due to the
past 12 months pandemic
but also with the rise of of um
artificial intelligence and computer
systems
i think we're all looking for that bit
of
an unusual um perspective and a take and
that's what creative people offer so
anything that um
shows that you are not a robot i think
is um is definitely going to be an
advantage
prove you can deliver the real thing at
the end but show some things that might
make you
make the the clients or the prospective
clients
yeah smile be inquisitive
remember i also think the idea itself is
often
um the most important thing but as um
we mentioned before and i think some of
the of the
we we questioned said it needs to be
well researched keeping in mind the
company it needs to fit well so you need
to have done all of your background work
before
and then the delivery of the first
concept is maybe less important but
the idea needs to obviously be good and
it needs to fit
um within the mo of whoever you're
proposing it to
so it's not whether it's a sketch or a
render or a photorealistic
um cgi or even a prototype it's more is
this the right product for this company
at this time and will it last and can i
create something from it yeah
thank you um there's a really good
question that came in earlier as well
that
it does seem a bit um similar but maybe
you could answer this as well which is
is it more effective to show one
specific design to a potential customer
or is it better to show a portfolio of
many different ideas to show the general
range of design work
um i'll just jump in here but again
gabriel probably has a better
perspective
i think our friend from uh the ceo of
gooby made the good point
um and a couple of others uh people said
yes a variety in some respects but
please
focus on what is right for that brand
um please target your work
to understand the brand and what they
need
it's it's important that you show that
you're not
just targeting everybody with the same
thing
that you have a variety of work you have
flexibility in your design
and creative skills but you have done
the homework to
show i think this particular piece is
right for you
and i think that shows a respect and an
understanding and an empathy
for the brand that you're dealing with
so a bit of both really
also i guess sorry um i mean are you
doing quantity
in the hope that something sticks or are
you doing quantity because you really
believe
that 15 of these designs are really good
so i think
and maybe gabriel has a different point
of view but i think
being more specific in the targeting of
a concept
is is definitely more effective spending
more time on one idea rather than
bombarding a company with 15
um is probably um you know more a more
efficient and strategic
way of doing it that's my point of view
i guess
yeah i think it's really about the the
context of
of the meeting or of the presentation if
it's something
about showing your breath of work over a
period of time or what you've been
researching into then you can show your
whole portfolio if you're presenting
face to face
not to tell them that everything is for
you but it's more like this is what i've
been working on
that is unpublished or over the past few
years
and then throughout that portfolio
presentation they may say oh this one or
two ideas are interesting and then you
also get a sense of
where they're heading or or what they're
looking for as a brand
but then if it's something that um that
you are emailing or
you are trying to propose specifically
for a brand then it's better to send
less ideas
whether it's just one or two ideas then
they really
feel like you have studied their brand
and designed something that is more
focused
to them so yeah i think both
it depends on on the context here
and maybe we okay we're we're up on time
but can we go another five minutes is
that okay is that allowed
yeah that's fine um we have a couple of
questions exactly there's a few more
being coming in
to see yeah so um i think we can go
through um two of the questions so
one of them is from from fabrice
uh he's asking it's good to hear from
the designer's perspective but
we should also hear from the editor's
point of view um in the role of an agent
to facilitate
business between the industry and design
so take it away
yeah take it away rosa yeah
so um i think he means that the role of
yeah and that's true actually this has
come up in some of the conversation that
um tony gabriel and i have had
leading up to it um so of course
designers and companies
are are crucial um to the creation of
design but then
yes as fabrice mentioned um an agent's
role in then bringing this design
out there and to customers and in front
of people is very important and actually
um one of the conversations we've had
um have been what are different ways
that
a design professional can help a company
can collaborate with a company that is
not strictly designing a product for
them
so there are so many different models of
collaboration and
what we found is and
we've mentioned this before companies
that already had a presence
in a territory were able to operate
there effectively so i think
um acting as a design company's agent
and i think this is what
fabrics mentioned um is a crucial
this is a crucial role and i think for
someone
wanting to get um into a design career
and establish a relationship with the
company to be able to help them
in a specific territory as it is perhaps
singapore in this case
could be a great way to establish a
strong connection
um gabriel what what what is your point
of view as someone being able to
operate both in europe and singapore
yeah i think
in some ways uh the designer is the
ambassador of the brand
when when i first started creative
directing aryake which was a japanese
brand
with no international track record we
were looking at
markets that we wanted to enter
and that was also how we based on which
designers we wanted to collaborate with
and invite to japan
for for the design workshops because
we we felt that yeah a designer is in
some way
gives you inside information on on a
certain country or a certain market
and at the same time they can design
products that are more suitable for
their home markets
so i think yeah
acting as a creative director has helped
me in that sense because i was
able to think from the other side as
well and then i could also see how
if i were to want to design for this
other brand i would
be able to offer the same qualities that
i look for
in designers i want to work with for for
the brands i created directly
thank you and i think we have one last
question um
from sujit so i mean he addressed it to
gabriel but i think we can hear from
from everyone
um which is in today's day and age do
you feel that a face-to-face
meeting is still needed with potential
clients or manufacturers
when virtually everything can be done
online especially now
you know in this covet era
yeah absolutely i think that the
face-to-face meetings are still super
important because
i think everyone is also suffering from
zoom fatigue um
i have asked yeah i mean
there are instances where i have asked
people for zoom meetings and people that
i met before and people that i know and
i sense a reluctance to get on zoom
calls because maybe they're just on too
many calls
imagine if you're a ceo of a design
company you're probably on calls
all day eight hours a day or six hours a
day so
to have another call with a designer
wanting to show you designs
maybe it's not on the top priority of
the agenda but then if you are actually
going there uh traveling a certain
distance and wanting to visit them
um they might view it as a form of
sincerity and and also
a way to see that you are investing in
in making a trip to understand them
better and
that will be more valuable and also
shows your
your seriousness and wanting to work
with someone yeah i can care with that i
think
as a lot of the feedback we got was
clear that
this progress in digital communication
has been incredible
and has saved us in the last 12 months
but it's only another string to our bow
there's nothing like the real thing and
as we've been hearing
trust is such the most important thing
between a designer
and a brand and a manufacturer a design
company and that
trust i don't think you can really get
it without
um sharing proper
physical time with each other whether
that be having a coffee a glass of wine
conversation
also the body language is so crucial
to building a relationship zoom is
wonderful in many respects but you don't
really get that human
interaction so yes it's been a fabulous
addition
and will continue to be like wow what an
amazing way to even do
this but it's still human beings coming
together
unquestionably is where the real magic
happens
and i i think that will continue so a
real positive in that the two will work
well together it's going to
really assist people outside your
singaporean designers that you can make
that introduction you can do that work
you can have meetings
and progress but yeah we all want to get
together and we all
really feel that that is the moment when
real
trust happens and you get through things
so much quicker
you can do five minutes face to face you
get it you get when people really
believe it on zoom you can
avoid things yeah you kind of you get
because it's you can't really tell
whether people
are very sincere and i think it's uh
yeah there's not there's nothing we'll
replace that
i think what is right is yes everything
can be done online but you can't
really establish a relationship online
so once you've done that once you've
established the relationship
face-to-face and you've created that
system
of trust and mutual respect and uh and
established ideas
then the next steps can be done like
i've spoken to designers
this year who found that they could
still collaborate with companies they
already had
like a very strong relationship with
without having to fly back and forth all
the time
but they had that relationship done
over the glasses of wine and you know by
being together in the factory for
example and by really getting to know
each other so
once you've once you've established it
in the relation it matters less where
you are
but you have to first be face to face to
to do that so it's definitely a mix of
the two
yeah so we're in a positive moment where
we have this tool now and um
i think it'll make the face to face that
much better as well
more efficiently nice digitally but then
it's it's it's really
yeah from our experience as i say you
get things done so much quicker
um with the face-to-face meeting you get
that immediate trust um
before we close i mean there was one
other question am i allowed to address
it mabel
i don't know whether it's a cheeky one i
don't think imran says is it essential
to come from a rich family to sustain a
living
as an entrepreneur industrial i would
say absolutely not
i think design and creativity and the
design business is all about
creativity and what you produce and does
not require
um coming from a wealthy background or
any privileges like that and i think
everybody is looking for
the real genuine quality i think in
architecture that has been an issue over
in the past it's changing that because
architecture is such a
long-winded education it takes so long
to
you know often you're not until your
late 40s 50s until you get anything
built
so it's inevitable that historically
it's been relatively wealthy people men
who have been able to sustain their
lifestyle
because they had personal wealth
and then they made it obviously talent
wins in the end so that has been tough i
think that is changing as well
fortunately but in design i think it's
far more nimble the profession
you find yourself being able to succeed
in many many different ways
in the broad area of design so no i mean
it's
you know and often you know there's
nothing like a bit of hunger
to um to really drive you to be more
creative
um being comfortable often doesn't um
provide the best motivation to be um to
be creative and it's
it's stamina perseverance all the things
gabriel said earlier about
just really staying in there um even if
your passport
has been stolen or people cancel your
meetings it doesn't matter where you're
rich poor or
or or anything it's just it's it's that
stamina and a passion and a belief in
in that what you do is is valuable um
so i think we probably should close up
shouldn't we mabel i have a little
something to share just to cure another
qr code
for answering for giving feedback um
but which i will put on the screen now
here we are lovely qr code for you
um we just seeing that qr code my q a
panel isn't showing is it yeah and just
to sum up um i did have a few slides of
something up but rosa went through them
but i think one thing we didn't
we talked about is um also
and gabriel it was your point earlier
that
these brands need you
as much as you need them and i think
more than ever now that
they need as many
creative and solutions to
to these problems that we have and you
as a designer
gabriel has been very good at this as
well is that you offer them something
and if you're
particularly singaporean based they
might need you know they'll need help in
terms of
finding resources or or people or
connections
in your territory so never go into this
relationship
completely like cap in hand please can i
work for you don't be so subservient
be humble of course as karola said be
be respectful but actually you've got a
lot to offer
these european brands they need to know
about asia they need to know about other
territories that they haven't got their
feet in
at the moment and i think yes you're
adding you're you're offering primarily
your design skills but you can offer
so much more and that's a really good
point that gabriel mentioned to me last
week and
what he's shown that yeah you are you
can solve many of their problems
more than just designing them a
beautiful piece of furniture so i think
that's
a positive positive thing think what you
have to offer
that is outside the normal parameters
of designing a product
so on that very positive note i think
mabel
shall we call it a day yes
please do scan this in give us your
feedback
um tell us what you feel about this
webinar on the business of design
program
um and i think we should bid farewell
just now if i can find the button where
i sign off i will but the sun has come
out in london
it's a positive time let's get design
going again
and uh and be in touch and i look
forward to seeing you all
again so thank you rosa thank you mabel
thank you gabriel thank you all for
joining us have a good
afternoon you
bye bye thank you